estas imágenes acercan a itía tomar un
respiro operarios mueren barricadas y
tratan de reconstruir la carretera es el
camino a un depósito de combustible que
estuvo bloqueado durante casi dos meses
estamos en un momento trágico para el
transporte desde el 12 de septiembre
usaron cualquier tipo de material para
hacer barricadas y bloquear el acceso
todas las existencias del país han visto
afectadas si observas las aduanas no
funcionan como antes el bloqueo del
depósito de combustible también bloqueó
las entregas que no se podían realizar
por el aumento del coste
el levantamiento se produce después de
que Jimmy cherisier alias barbecue
anunciara el domingo que levantaba el
bloqueo en estos dos meses el líder de
La Poderosa pandilla g9 cortó el acceso
a unos 45,4 millones de litros de diesel
y gasolina y más de 3 millones de litros
de queroseno justificó el bloqueo como
una forma de exigir la renuncia del
Primer Ministro Ariel Henry
nosotros el grupo de trabajo
revolucionario g9 le pedimos a cualquier
camionero de los que están preocupados
por el tema de la gasolina que tome las
medidas para que el combustible pueda
salir y llegar a las estaciones la
escasez de combustible obligó a cerrar
gasolineras a limitar los horarios de
bancos y supermercados y a reducir los
servicios hospitalarios afectando al
recrudecimiento de un brote de cólera en
un país donde el 60% de la población es
pobre y con unas pandillas cada vez más
poderosas